it's just plain stupid out there up food
when it can easily be eaten just because
some label is strongly marked you know
circus food is all the food that's on
the way people get rid of it either
because of big issues packaging or
whatever store like view it really helps
open the discussion and get people open
to the idea that hey let's do something
with all this food that could be eaten
it's cheaper for me and it's always an
adventure to go in here and see what
they have because it's not always the
same things my favorite things I bought
from here was this fear that they
weren't gonna be of the sell they have
produced for some of the events and they
just costed the dollar and there were
really really good beer
you